segundo bloque economía aquí en directo
américa de france 24 y nuevamente con
micro el estudio daniela blandón dan y
rusia ya fijó la fecha para que le
empiecen a pagar en rublos así es de
raúl pues el presidente vladimir putin
reveló que ya firmó el decreto para que
a partir del primero de abril los
compradores de su gas tengan que pagar
en rublos agregó que tendrán que abrir
cuentas en gazprombank y que si no se
hace de esta manera pues suspenderán los
contratos el kremlin busca aplicar esta
medida sólo a los países que considera
hostiles es decir aquellos que se han
unido al boicot occidental en su contra
como una forma de fortalecer su
soberanía dice el presidente putin horas
antes sin embargo el gobierno alemana
había asegurado que en conversación
telefónica con el canciller alemán olaf
scholz el jefe del kremlin le había
dicho que si podría seguir usando euros
y dólares por ahora esto fue lo que
explicó hoy el gobierno ruso
de facto sería de facto no habrá cambio
para los receptores de gas ruso que
paguen estos envíos de mínimo jet
en cualquier caso están comprando rublos
por la moneda estipulada en los
contratos rusia sigue comprometida con
todas las obligaciones establecidas en
los contratos y acuerdos vigentes tanto
en términos de cantidad y precio
etcétera
habrá que ver entonces el desarrollo
raúl porque a mí me quedaron más dudas
que respuestas después de estas
declaraciones sin embargo el solo
anuncio del mayor productor de gas del
mundo de que ya solamente va a recibir
rublos ha hecho temblar a europa allí
los gobiernos temen por una posible
escasez de gas natural inclusive a
alemania ya había encendido una alerta
temprana pues daniela a todos nos
quedaron más dudas vamos a ver entonces
qué iba a pasar y hay noticias
económicas también agridulces para
europa sí señor los precios al
consumidor en marzo aumentaron con más
fuerza en las principales economías de
europa a medida que los hogares pues se
enfrentan a los altos costos de la
energía y también algunos alimentos todo
por la rusa de ucrania la inflación en
españa alcanzó un 10 por ciento en el
último año con corte a marzo esto es un
ritmo más rápido desde mayo de 1985 en
alemania el aumento del 76 por ciento en
marzo es el más alto en 40 años sigue a
italia con una alza del 7% mientras que
en francia los precios avanzaron 5,1 por
ciento impulsados también por
combustibles y gas naturales cuál es la
buena noticia es que está por el lado
del desempleo que fue del 68 por ciento
en febrero y marcó un recorte mínimo
desde que iniciaron registros en 1998
aún así hay 11,1 millones de personas
sin trabajo en los 19 países que
comparten el euro y porque los países
exportadores de petróleo le hacen oídos
sordos a eeuu pues mire la opep que es
la organización de países exportadores
de petróleo y sus aliados liderados por
rusia acordaron este jueves otro modesto
aumento mensual de la producción de
petróleo a partir de mayo esto es de un
poco más de 430 mil barriles por día sin
embargo se están resistiendo a la
presión bombear más petróleo esto se lo
ha venido pidiendo eeuu también
abandonaron a la agencia internacional
de energía con alrededor de 30 miembros
y sede en parís como fuente de datos
confiable esto es una señal raúl de un
endurecimiento del tono frente a
occidente por otro lado pues eeuu se
estaría considerando liberar 180
millones de barriles de su reserva
estratégica esto sería la liberación más
grande en casi medio siglo y tiene a los
precios del petróleo cayendo más del 5%
se espera que el presidente bailen haga
la anuncio en las próximas sobre
noticias de nuestra región danny el año
pasado muy 21 bajó la pobreza en
argentina se ubicó exactamente en 37 3%
en el segundo semestre 33 puntos por
debajo del primer semestre y todavía la
cifra es mejor si se compara con la tasa
del 42 por ciento de un año antes en
términos reales esto quiere decir que
2,6 millones de hogares viven con
ingresos por debajo de la línea de
pobreza o 10 8 millones de personas
también 578.000 hogares o 24 millones de
personas están en la indigencia lo que
sí hay que aclarar es que esta medición
se hace con relación al nivel de vida de
los 31 centros urbanos más poblados del
país es decir que abarca 29 millones de
personas y no a la población completa de
argentina que es de 45 millones danny
indicadores económicos los mercados
bursátiles asiáticos cayeron el jueves
después de conocerse un debilitamiento
de la manufactura china también los
mercados están muy atentos a los nuevos
bombardeos rusos que han sacudido las
esperanzas de progresos en las
conversaciones entre rusia y ucrania y
las acciones de rusia marcaron su peor
trimestre en 13 años en la bolsa estuvo
cerrada por varios días por la guerra
danny gracias entonces por toda la
información económica el día de hoy nos
vemos con más próximamente y pasamos
ahora hasta parís